i'm going to take you back 10 years and
this is kind of interesting especially
for a lot of guys
in america and california
around the 10-year mark of marriage she
and i were arguing a lot
about where we should live she wanted to
stay in the city she wanted to be the
cool city girl and i wanted to see
coincidence that at the 10-year mark
where she knows that you're on the hook
for lifelong alimony that she became a
little more disagreeable
oh it's no question
she knew what she had i knew what she
had i i'm no dummy you know i i knew it
was a mistake but
you know we had a great life we even we
were living in oakland
we
you know
we were
i wasn't super rich but i did good you
know and i wake up every morning and
have jobs to do and very well respected
and we would
help build the little elementary school
in our town and
all the good stuff you know
and kids go running around all the time
and um
so
i kind of lost my train of thought we
were um you're you're talking about 10
years back with this guy that you had to
build oh yeah
so
because we're arguing
she wants to go see a shrink
go
couples counsel
okay
so we go and
turns in she she convinces them that i
have the problem
and i'm
sorry i'm not laughing at you i'm just
it's like see i was right again but yeah
go ahead yeah i have the problem i have
the problem because i'm angry because i
was like look we got 10 million bucks
how much more could we you know just put
that in a freaking simple six percent
thing or even 10 or we don't have to put
in anything we own properties i mean
they're spitting out cash and
it's like we could we don't need to have
a second and third house if we just have
our one house and then there all the
time and i always was gonna put my
moniker of success to myself was that i
get to see my house in the daytime
because
i work from before sunrise to after
sunset
every morning i'd wake up at six i'd be
first one down at the lumber yard make
sure everybody's gonna have enough
materials
yeah
and then when i come home at night and
well once a while we had a little fun at
sneak home because i lived very close to
all my jobs you know you get a little
nicky in the afternoon that was fun it
was great you know and and uh
and then we get to go um
on three day vacations to the mountain
house and once in a while we take off
for two weeks and go to things it was
great you know it's like
but
but at 10 years i was like
[Music]
how much more do we need
and let's do some different things let's
go explore the world i haven't i haven't
seen the rest of the world i haven't
seen europe i want to do this when my
kids are small
and that's when the resistance started
and i was like what is going on so she
said we gotta you're not happy
you we gotta go see a shrink
so we went together
and then after a while
she was like you know i'm just
frustrated trying to explain to this guy
and to her why we should do this now
and i probably wasn't the best
communicator
whatever they convinced me i should go
on prozac
i'll put you on antidepressants
yeah and i did not want
i was like
i'm not depressed
i'm pissed
[Laughter]
i just want to go on a sailboat from
time to time man that's my medicine i
don't need these pills well yeah well i
wanted to park all the jobs we have and
take the kids and introduce something oh
god yeah totally but but instead you got
put on like antidepressants right
because you're
you know
you know imagine that you're married you
know you've done the right thing your
entire life you've raised a family
you've built a business you're loaded
you've got a plane you've got multiple
houses you got vacation houses and it's
like you just want to sail a boat and
you go to a therapist and the guy's like
here take these pills and shut up
dude i wasn't even asking for life i was
asking for a year yeah one year i said
listen let's just go for a [ __ ] year
and we'll find a boat somewhere i don't
know i'll figure it out i figure
everything else out i mean
my god i've i've had you know i've done
all this stuff i built houses on
hillsides in the middle of winter i'm
starting to get some wind from your mic
i don't know if you can move closer to
the cabin
okay
so um
so
i
have that yeah yeah that's better to sit
on my instead of my toolbox even better
so
i um
i realized okay so
this is classic
ten years
more go eight years more go by oh we
moved by the way
after that ten there was part of the
video i said all right you want me to go
frozen
i'll tell you what i'll make a deal i'll
take your pros out
but we're moving to central california
that's the deal
because that'll be like a halfway
and i'm going to call it my boat
so i bought 10 acres
1331 tiffany ranch road look it up
and see how beautiful that property is
it's on you know realtor.com or whatever
1331 tiffany ranch yeah and uh just it's
a gorgeous place i built so many
beautiful places
from beginning to end by the way my my
my production flow of my life over 30
years
on an average of every 120 days so think
where you were four months ago
where are we now we're december 14th so
that'll be august september october
november december so from august 14th to
where were you
middle summer and now it's december 14th
august september october november
december yeah
in that time
every 120 days for 30 years i would
produce a property like that
and put it on the market is that it
there
that's it yeah you can see it from the
sky and if you go on like the
realtor.com thing you can see it there's
probably beautiful pictures of it all
built out yes
tiffany ranch road in san luis obispo
yeah it's ranch yeah
anyway so
you know it's uh but that's what i did
and um
so
i
i said look
let's
move down here because then i can call
this agree to that yeah she agreed yeah
so we went
so i mean you're all based out on these
antidepressants
yeah
and they're kind of a joke because
here's the thing for me anyway when i
took prozac
slows you down it slows you down and
makes you fat it takes away your sexual
desire it does a lot of things to you
yeah and and actually i was still having
a you know we'd still sex was fine it
didn't really slow that down for me but
it definitely like if a bomb went off
behind me
you need to turn around and go with the
[ __ ] you know let's fight back
you give a [ __ ]
and i was like why is this good and
so
i i uh i was like yeah whatever and i
tried to go off of them sometimes and
it's horrible in your brain
anyway this guy
dr cherry is a renowned
uh
shrink in the bay area
and he actually runs
a place called the thunder road clinic
in um
oakland it's where a lot of wayward kids
end up and so he
he uh kind of sets policy on that so his
name
is
you know he's a upstanding guide so of
course we go to him
and um
all right so we take the drugs and then
we move away
i do want to talk about the boat dwayne
and i've got like 25 minutes left
because i gotta hop on another call so i
just wanted to make sure we have enough
time to talk about the boat and the new
lifestyle too so i'll get you there
so
i end up uh eight years later i get this
phone call
and i get hey somebody i know needs to
build a house up in oakland and i needed
to work
because the middle of the recession
and so i did these plans and i bid them
i don't even know who it's for it's this
beautiful house
uh in oakland or in orenda
modern
and the guy finally gets the bid and
then he calls me
and he says hey i got your bid it's
amazing it's like a million and a half
bucks
and
and he says and i start
listening i go hey man i recognize your
voice like wait a minute this your plans
say schwinn cherry
okay you're david chair you're my old
shrink
he goes he goes yeah i was like
oh that's that's your wife's name
schwinn because yeah so we hyphenated
twin cherry
okay
and i said well wait a minute is this
okay i built your house because yeah you
know you want i mean
are you okay with it i said yeah you
know
whatever so it's a good house and i need
the money and
so we let's do this so we do yeah 18
months goes by
one day i walk into his house it's like
80 done and i just look like hell and he
goes what's matter i said i'm getting a
divorce he goes
oh my god now the thing is when you
build someone's home
you get to know them better than anybody
else
like better
better than their shrink wood because
they people can find things in you when
you build their home that they wouldn't
even confide
well how he treats his wife
how he thought about marriage how he
perceives himself to his kids his
relationship to other people because
people present themselves that way
through their homes
how they want their car to be seen in
the driveway how they
um and you know even pitting themselves
against their spouse like clean don't
you think this fork knife would be
better on this side than that side even
though his wife wants it on the other
side
it's like oh you're going to use me for
your battles
fight your own battles
okay that's quite the lesson
yeah so this happens all the time in
customers as i say not as i do sort of
thing
yeah
yeah so then i started looking at this
guy going you're the one who was
counseling us yeah okay
that day i walked in i said what's up i
said i'm getting a divorce he's like oh
my god that's horrible i'm so sorry
you know well can you finish my house i
said yeah i'll get your house finished
so
after i finished it
last day
he gives me my final payoff check
and i said hey come here
i want to step off your property
walk over and i said all right this is
the property line right i go
i'm done with your house right because
yeah it's beautiful i love it
everything's perfect okay and i said and
you and i have no more business after
this yeah i said all right
so if you hand me the money so it gives
it to me off the property and i said now
okay i want to ask you something now
that we're on we're neutral man standing
on neutral property
do you think he did the right thing
eight years ago prescribing me that
after you know me now
and he said no
i said thank you
so basically
he had the wall poles over his eyes
because
now he got to know me
mano building his house right
and how i managed stuff and sure i'd
yell at the drywall hanger some days
like what the [ __ ] are you doing you
know you're upside down
but he knew some people just don't
respond any other way and then he saw
the stresses of spending a couple
million bucks that's the hardest thing
you'll ever do in your life probably the
biggest asset you'll ever own
and he got nervous too
and many times i had to calm him down
so so then he was like oh i got it he
realized he'd been juked
by
the system
so
these guys know what they're doing it's
you know it's about it's about their
priorities and i always tell guys to be
very cautious when it comes to
therapists because like like even today
it's worse than it was back when you
were dealing with it because now even
the apa has guidelines basically
telling therapists and counselors to
treat men
as if they're toxically masculine right
that that it's always going to be you is
the problem so even back then they still
treated you as the problem
well okay so here's the thing that i
didn't realize then
that was the setup
oh
because now he's got this thing that
says oh he was on
drugs oh that's why she wanted you on
the yes that's why she jumped up and
down and pointed the finger and i was
like gotcha
you